hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt heute gibt's teil 1 von salis
classics ich werde heute eine linzer
torte backen
sallys classics kind sind es noch nicht
ja und zwar werde ich in dieser
kategorie ein paar klassische rezepte
machen oder was ist ein paar dienstag
hatte gering nur klassische rezepte
machen und möchte eben mit der linzer
torte starten und zeigt euch jetzt
einmal die zutaten für den teig brauchen
wir drei 100 gramm mehl 125 gramm butter
die ist immer warm 125 gramm gemahlene
haselnüsse 200 gramm zucker
jetzt habe ich hier eine mischung und
zwar habe ich hier einen teelöffel
backpulver eine messerspitze nelke die
habe ich verdrückt
hier habe ich noch einen teelöffel zimt
und hier habe ich außerdem noch einen
teelöffel lebkuchengewürz das ist ein
geheimrezept von unserem bäckermeister
der hat nämlich echt die beste linzer
torte und ich habe das bisher noch nicht
ausprobiert wohl seine linzertorten
umoperieren und das fast ein geheimtipp
den ich bekommen habe
wir brauchen einen halb esslöffel
kakaopulver und ihr braucht etwas milch
und zwar so viel dass wir gleich sehen
wenn mit den teig machen so viel dass
der teig eben geschmeidig genug ist und
das ist ein schöner tag wird und
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier mal ein
glas milch was machst du da nicht klauen
und da nehmen wir uns dann gleich so
viel wie wir brauchen denn jeder größe
ist ja anders und deswegen kann sein
dass ihr mal mehr und mal weniger
benötigt aus diesen zutaten wird jetzt
ein teig hergestellt und das zeige ich
euch jetzt und die linzer torte werde
ich heute in einer springform ich hab
hier wieder eine rosafarbene weil ich ja
immer noch ausprobieren und zwar sollte
er am durchmesser von 24 bis 28 cm
nehmen für die springform größe ist der
teig ausgelegt zuerst gebe ich jetzt die
butter in den rumtopf können natürlich
auch alles mit der hand verkneten
oder früher oder mit einem handrührgerät
aber ich mache jetzt in meinem
standmixer in der kitchenaid und da gebe
ich jetzt während im rühren den zucker
mit dazu und danach kommt es mit rein
und wenn sich das so ein bisschen
verrührt hat kommen die trockenen
zutaten mit rein also die gewürze
backpulver kakaopulver haselnüsse und
das mehl und hier gebe ich jetzt einfach
so ein schluck milch mit dazu erstmal
mit wenig starten und dann kann man
immer noch während dem prozess mehr dazu
geben da sieht man den lippenstift
abdruck unter samira
lebt als auch nicht so viel mehr
schreien also das soll so werden wie so
ein urteil soll kein rührteig sein
der teig ist jetzt gemacht da müsst ihr
darauf achten dass sie nicht zu viel
milch nehmen dabei auch nicht zu wenig
also es war richtig schön feucht sein
aber eben nicht so flüssig wie so ein
rührteig die form muss jetzt noch
vorbereitet werden
dafür hätte ich sie jetzt einmal ein
kanal mit butter machen
dann gebe ich doch etwas mailen drauf
normalerweise haftet das nicht daran
aber ich gehe immer auf nummer sicher
und macht das lieber noch mal mit mehl
für die füllung braucht ihr das
pflaumenmus da streiten sich manchmal
die geister toben also ich find in den
linzer torte gehört pflaumenmus manche
sagen danke hat himbeermarmelade rein
oder erdbeer aber ich finde blaue
musisch wirklichen muss auch wenn man
das so vielleicht als brotaufstrich
nicht so gerne hat finde ich sollte man
die linzer torte pflaumenmus geben
den teig hab ich jetzt hier wie gesagt
ich stelle etwas feucht man könnte ihn
jetzt auch etwas kühl stellen
du bist auch ein bisschen her jetzt
nehme ich hier von etwa so eine handvoll
weg das brauche ich dann nämlich für den
rand und für die gitterstäbe und dieses
hier nehme ich jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen weg ein bisschen mehr an
das nehme ich jetzt einfach so braucht
er nicht ausrollen
ob das werde ich jetzt einfach mit den
fingern in die formen drücken dann wird
es einfach von der imagine draußen
gedrückt
wenn es zu arg lebt dann wählte eure
hände ein bisschen wird nämlich das
pflaumenmus und gibt es hier mit rein da
könnt ihr so viel nehmen wie ihr möchtet
in diesem becher sind jetzt 200 kaum
drin und ich verteile zumal das bisschen
am besten mit einer wickel palette
ich lasse einen kleinen rand außen frei
damit eben die marmelade dieses
pflaumenmus nicht an meinem torten an
meinen springform rand klebt jetzt müsst
ihr aus diesem rest tag noch den rand
und die gitterstäbe formen und es könnte
jetzt entweder so machen dass ihr das
hier mit etwas milch verrührt und dann
mit einem spritzbeutel drauf spritzt
sieht schön aus finde ich aber bisher in
schwierig das dann zu spritzen oder ihr
könnt das auch jetzt mit der hand formen
das wette ich jetzt gleich machen
ihr könnt auch den teig etwas fester
machen mit etwas mehl und ausrollen und
kleine herzzellen oder tannenbäume oder
sterne ausstechen und die an den rand
legen
ich werde euch das jetzt einfach mal so
zeigen
ich werde jetzt einfach hier so rolle
und schneiden meter kurzen stück ab ich
beginne jetzt am rand drückt es leicht
flach und nehmt es dann mit einer
palette auf oder mit einem langen messer
und dann könnte das da drüben auf dem
kuchen geben
ich muss mir das jetzt so ein bisschen
mit der palette ab dann wieder flach
drücken
ein
so und aus dem rest form die jetzt noch
einen schönen rand genau nach dem
gleichen prinzip einfach lang ausrollen
und flach drücken
so viel torte aus wenn ihr sie fertig
dekoriert habt wie gesagt könnt ihr da
alles mögliche machen ihr könnt die
buchstaben ausstechen formen ausstechen
mit dem fixer gretchen die gitterstäbe
ausschneiden ich finde sie so ganz schön
weil sie soeben handgemacht und
selbstgemachte aussieht ihr könnt
übrigens im teig auch einen esslöffel
kirschwasser mit hinzufügen oder einen
esslöffel rum
das schmeckt auch ganz gut ich wollte
heute aber auch auf alkohol verzichten
es gibt einfach so ein schönes aroma
noch mit rein linde torten gibt es
natürlich auch zu kaufen bei aldi lidl
und so weiter aber die selbst gemachtem
ist da wirklich mal probieren die
schmeckt so lecker und ich freue mich
jetzt schon sehen den ofen zu schieben
weil dann die ganze wohnung nach linzer
torte riecht und zwar musste jetzt bei
ober und unterhitze bei 160 grad etwa 30
minuten gebacken werden
sie darf nicht zu lange gebacken werden
weil sie sonst zu trocken wird und zu
hart und dann zeige ich euch das
endergebnis könnt ihr es riechen
die linzer torte ist jetzt fertig und
ich werde euch jetzt mal zeigen so
lecker sieht es jetzt aus
ich habs jetzt so etwa 20 minuten
abkühlen lassen und welz aus der form
lösen
sz da muss ich jetzt auch nicht mit
einem messer außen herum fahren das geht
ganz einfach
und jetzt werde ich sie hier mit einem
torten retter anheben
ganz vorsichtig die ich nämlich noch
warm dann kann ich sehr auf meinen
torten auf eine tortenplatte servieren
dann könnt ihr noch seine torten spitze
nehmen sich an klassischer kuchen kann
muss eine torten spitze auch sein und
dann könnte den kuchen ganz einfach da
drauf gleiten lassen sehr vorsichtig
jetzt klebt ein bisschen damit so lange
gewartet
wenn es nicht geht einfach mit einer
palette anheben und jetzt müsste ich
eigentlich alle zu mir nach hause
einladen damit er diesen duft von dieser
linzer torte in eurer nase spüren könnt
linzer traute schmeckt ja eigentlich am
besten wenn sie ein paar tage
durchziehen kann also die schmeckt auch
noch nach einer woche richtig lecker
wichtig ist mir immer an der linzer
torte dass sie schön feucht bleibt also
dass sie nicht trocken wird das heißt
ihr müsst ihr dann eben schön abdecken
und am besten in geschlossenen behälter
geben da entfaltet so richtig schön die
aromen und schmeckt dann richtig klasse
ich werde jetzt auch noch nicht
anschneiden weil sie mir noch zu warm
ist ich mag es allerdings auch ganz
gerne warm
das rezept werde ich euch natürlich auf
meinem blog verlinken und weitester
wieder schreiben
ihr könnt es natürlich auch auf einem
backblech packen also könnt ihr auch mit
diesem backblech backen mit dem bug
rahmen da das doppelte rezept nehmen
damit es eben von der menge erreicht am
mittwoch bekommt ihr wieder neues video
von mir da weil ich ja wie angesprochen
schon etwas verbraucherbildung machen
und dann eben auf die firma kendo zu
sprechen kommen
ich habe mich übrigens sehr gefreut dass
das neue thema also dieser
verbraucherbildung und diese
lebensmittelkennzeichnung textil
kennzeichnung dass es so gut bei euch
angekommen ist ich habe mir schon die
ganzen kommentare durchgelesen und schon
beantwortet und da freue ich mich
wirklich sehr dass sie auch daran
interessiert sein
und es wäre wirklich gemeinsam machen
jetzt wünsche ich euch noch einen ganz
schönen tag
ich würde mich natürlich freuen wenn ihr
dieses rezept ausprobiert und mir die
fotos bei facebook oder instagram postet
immer mit einer verlinkung zu mir damit
ich das auch sehen was ich noch sagen
wollte manchmal kann ich kommentare bei
youtube nicht beantworten weil er dann
euer google plus konto nicht mit youtube
verbunden habt und ich kann daran nicht
darauf antworten das finde ich sehr
schade weil ich wirklich jeden kommentar
beantworte da solltet ihr darauf achten
und ich freue mich natürlich wenn ihr
meinen video bewertet und es teilt und
wegsehens beim nächsten mal wieder biss
dann teams
ich schneide jetzt doch an ich kann
nicht still
stimmt ich ganz vergessen
naja man kann doch kein land hat eine
woche stehe lasse nicht mehr immer
gleich probieren
sehr gut war